[Music]
music anymore okay find that fine then
I'm just gonna have a whole video me
rocking out to that awesome music okay
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play give up since
you guys seem to like to watch me
struggle and die repeatedly
unnecessarily I might add I'm gonna try
this game don't know why a new
challenger this made by Jay MTB who is
one of my favorite flash programmers to
ever arrow keys to go oh what's gonna
stop me what's gonna stop me what's
gonna stop me oh okay these are just
warm-ups okay so far so good doesn't
seem so bad I can double jump
seems pretty standard fare yeah I know
already knew I could double jump didn't
need to tell me man music is awesome you
will be giving up soon well probably not
well actually probably so I'm a
notorious giver-upper when you get tired
just push the big blue button
hahaha the one that says failure it
doesn't say failure it says good give up
uh-huh
so far so good I'm not dead not dead not
dead yet not dead yet not dead yet huh
like a mouse so bro for you OOP nope I'm
not gonna press it is this actually I I
have a feeling this game it's gonna
start trolling me any minute now but
anyway oh hello ah oh boy yeah this just
got incrementally a lot harder why oh
boy ha OH
to pro I got my super meatboy skills all
up in this [ __ ]
Oh a gun that hardly seems fair
ah ah I don't know attract me and bull
this bull okay now I gotta get my [ __ ]
ah ha ha [ __ ] [ __ ] off I'm the best all
right I am I am already so Pro you don't
even understand how Pro I is this is
bull this whole game is BA
oh [ __ ] okay yeah it's starting to get a
little harder now
oh boy still love that music f [ __ ]
how can touch in this I'm gonna go this
way ah best oh here we go
gotta learn how to jump ah oh I almost
had it
okay really racking up the death now ah
come on
I'm just taking the hard way because I
hate myself
- probably why ah [ __ ] right under those
spikes I'm an idiot
oh god is gonna do okay I can tell
already what the title of this game is
gonna be my [ __ ] pop-up myth may check
do you think you are an [ __ ] that's
where you are okay
Oh too skilled us just to off [ __ ] oh
okay let me get back into cocky mode oh
just shoot ah [ __ ] ah
huh I'm gonna homeboy is gonna this is
where I lose my mind
ah MITM a dick oh yes ah [ __ ]
somebody's cheating here whoop miss me
Oh with that miss me again ha ha ha ha
[ __ ] [ __ ] ow I'm the best I am the
great effect ha ha again yeah ok this is
hardly what I would call fair but then
again is given that the name of the game
is huh oh I'm not gonna give up I can't
give up oh I get it
ok oh boy oh boy
ok all right why why are you doing this
oh okay come on I can do this
ahh I cannot do this I didn't even isn't
even fair Oh bollocks ha ha oh God Oh
oh my god I'm like on the wrong feet ah
come on come on oh [ __ ] yeah hey I gotta
go under gotta go under that's the only
way ah let's see alright ha ha [ __ ]
[ __ ] ah I bet huh [ __ ] I gotta go under
how did I go under last time I went so
easy it was like I made it happen like
just with my mind
haha met me
oh yeah Oh too proud for you I'm
straight ah I can't even you're not
vegan let me oh hey Oh itch [ __ ] you
finally
god damn oh god oh god I'm not a precise
person I I have no precision skills ah
yeah what I know you're all laughing at
me I would love to see you guys try huh
oh let me oh ah ha ha ha ha ha ha I
thought you got me but you did not you
did not got me oh oh [ __ ] Oh horseshit
this is all horse Jack horse hockey
poopy poopy balls come on jump right
into it
ah [ __ ] I'm such an a-hole huh Hey ah ah
scrotie mcboogerballs [ __ ] ah how Jesus
Christ on a cracker jack
Oh the worst is that person even talking
to me sug I can't even I wasn't even
paying attention I think that computer
was taunting me this whole time but I
wasn't paying attention
why would I care why would I care about
anything that's got going on there Oh
God I know this good scheme plays it's
gonna be 10 minutes of me screaming my
head off I lose my voice I never lose my
ha
okay there we go
Oh oh that's a vicious circle you get
lose you lose one and then you're just
gone you okay let me think about this
let me think while I'm dodging this if I
do this I can get through here a bit
quicker but huh and then hopefully be
out of Oh hahaha okay I got to get
through this stuff but gotta get through
this level I know the next one's gonna
be even harder but I don't care
got to get through this one this is the
one I'm worried about Oh my timing is so
off
ah that's so bad Oh
okay alright okay thinking about this
again
Oh oh god no matter where I go I'm my
timing is off everywhere it's like [ __ ]
your mark I don't give a [ __ ] about you
or your happiness I hope you go dine I
got it well I can't why can't I get I
was able to get past that so many times
before
and now I'm just like I'm flabbergasted
that's the only word I can use to
describe this I'm flabbergasted at the
atrocities that are being perforated on
my face
Wow why I haven't died there yet why not
ha ha ha ha ha I'm trying I'm
persevering through adversity I am a
champion who back you
okay this isn't that hard Baba
why haven't you fallen why are you not
fall fall ah why is this not falling it
was falling before and it suddenly
decides not to fall is that how we're
playing this guy [ __ ] me
Oh sounds right there oh right there
oh man I was right there ah is right
there and now then those who hose right
there I can't believe the [ __ ] beggary
that was the aw [ __ ] man Jesus I'm gonna
turn to hard drugs after this my life
cannot get worse my life is like an oh
you son of a [ __ ] you oh wow I don't
even know how I don't even know how
they're getting me anymore
but they are cuz I mean I try I try to
live a good life but I think this is how
evil masterminds are born
that's me that time oh now you fall and
now you're gonna let me oh okay I'm done
after 129 deaths and that all right hang
on let me see what the lasers like if
it's as big a [ __ ] bag as I think it is
well I mean this isn't that hard if I
can just go under it you love later I
love lamp
a little imp or lamp it's still good I
love it okay well laser doesn't seem
that hard but I can just go under it
maybe I can go forward that doesn't seem
bad Wow where'd you come from
pissed off
haha man talk about perseverance I'm
there oh boy hello hi you're here early
hey whoa these guys are here awfully
early oh boy
that don't look good Oh Oh to prefer you
oh my god where'd you come from
good man fur trap [ __ ] huh Burke tribe
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah oh I'm on a roll
I can't be stopped
okay bro oh I wasn't bro enough for that
oh oh you can't stop me now Oh dodging
you like vows ah [ __ ] okay this is
officially impossible ha ha ha holy [ __ ]
are you seeing I'm seeing oh man what
the [ __ ] ha how would anyone be able to
do this oh my god holy balls
no I'm I can't I jump and I I can't get
to the ground fast enough holy balls
oh man oh not you too
Oh kill me hard ah hell is this oh man
follows in on a roll I would have
stopped a long time ago oh man what the
[ __ ] huh hey boss hey boss
ha ha ha oh [ __ ] hell a ridiculous
holy crap oh man oh man oh man oh man oh
come on oh right there
rah rah rah rah rah rah rah rah I keep
thinking about double jumps gonna be
enough to get me to where I need to go
but apparently that's not the case
all these need a double jump ah holy
[ __ ] how this this is what hell looks
like everybody this is what purgatory is
and I am in it I am in it to lose it I
am in it for eternity and I will be this
is my punishment for I don't know what
but I mean holy how on a cracker
so bad I even know how this would be
even a little bit possible stop the pain
okay this is oh my god you I don't even
know okay that is officially my N floor
30 I cannot beat I'm not even gonna try
i but click this give up button see what
it does I give up I gave up I officially
gave up it's not okay it's not okay Brad
dad okay bruh
was a good time you can try I gave it my
best game of a failure and regret Oh God
all right so anyway good job jmt po2 is
one of my favorite game programmers of
all time he's amazing he's got so many
awesome games go try them out oh man if
you guys can beat my high score get as
far as I got
be my guest go ahead and try I don't
care if you do congratulations to the
bad ending links in the description
below so thank you everybody for
watching click the annotations if
they're working win for more videos I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video
[Music]
[ __ ]
god
[Music]